what's up everybody I'm Walter Bernays
yak and this is top five Yuri countdown
the best and worst performances of our
most beloved actors today we take a look
at the worst of everybody's favourite
long-distance runner
Tom Cruise last week we discussed his
best but now it's time to get down to
the worst Tom Cruise in general is a
likable and bankable star but he can't
be hit or miss some ups and downs in his
career have led to some interesting
parts for him to play so with his newest
movie Jack Reacher never go back hitting
theaters a couple weekends ago let's
take a look at the top 5 worst Tom
Cruise performances number 5 Joseph
donelly in far and away cruise plays an
Irishman who comes to America in search
of land that he can claim as his own
like a few other movies from around this
time period Nicole Kidman is there too
after his father dies and his house is
burned to the ground Joseph donelly and
his rich landlord's daughter Shannon
sneaked away to America looking to claim
open land for themselves in Oklahoma
however they get stuck in Boston where
Shannon works as a feather plucker and
Joseph takes up bare-knuckle fighting to
help keep them afloat as an affection
build between the two they are casted
out on the street with no home joseph
wonders if Shannon would be better off
without him so Cruz isn't all that bad
in this actually there are a few parts
when he's quite good his performance
starts to take a turn when the movie
goes off the rails a little bit about an
hour and a half into this two and a half
hour affair yeah it's a long movie that
feels very long I think everyone suffers
from this as the third act of this film
drags all the performances down with it
by the time we get near the end we care
less about cruises character and it
turns very sappy Cruz doesn't play those
romantic scenes very well in this but it
does punch a horse the very ending is
also pretty ridiculous and more over the
top and the rest of the movie I won't
spoil it for you but see if you can find
the last scene it's very out of place
Ron Howard directed this continent
spanning epic and while Cruz gets a few
good moments in we all know he's done
much much better
number four Stacee Jaxx in Rock of Ages
Tom Cruise plays an aging rock star in
the late 80s I can actually see him
doing pretty grit with a roll like this
unfortunately he plays Stacee Jaxx in a
bad movie that calls for this character
and his performance to go in the wrong
direction based on the rock jukebox
musical Rock of Ages features the songs
of journey
Bon Jovi Def Leppard and others it tells
the tale of Midwestern singer Cherie
Christian who just arrived in Hollywood
looking to make it big upon arriving she
meets drew a local bar back and together
they work towards making their dreams
come true however an encounter with rock
icon Stacee Jaxx
tests their relationship in many ways
both individually and together this is
on the worst list because it's a missed
opportunity if he played this kind of
role in a serious movie about the
astronomical highs and soul-crushing
lows of a rocker in the 80s I'm sure he
would have killed it
but in this he's forced to be goofy
because this movie is stupid we have to
talk about his singing voice Cruz really
worked hard on this aspect of the
character and his seeing isn't that bad
sometimes it's pretty good
then sometimes it sounds like he just
inhaled a tank of helium Cruz tries to
encapsulate the aura of a big rock star
like that and he does hit a few of those
characteristics well but there are times
when it's way overdone and in a movie
like this that's saying a lot
let me tell you so I know me better than
anyone because I live here one redeeming
thing about the movie is Stacee Jaxx's
monkey I think that the film would have
been better if it was just about his
misadventures hey hey man man
Cruz captures something in this role but
it's not good enough to keep it off the
worst list number three Vincent Lauria
in the color of money this is a
well-respected Martin Scorsese movie
that features a great performance from
Paul Newman once again Cruz isn't all
that bad in this one but some of his
characters awkwardness gets in the way
of what could have been a really good
role for him in this sequel to 1961 s
The Hustler Eddie Felson a former pool
hustler makes a comeback with a talented
yet unfocused young man named Vincent
they go on the road as Eddie teaches
Vincent the art of the scam and slowly
build up a friendship however their
ideologies too often clash as they go
their separate ways
Eddie then decides to pick up the game
once again and this leads to a showdown
between teacher and student in Atlantic
City this is based off the 1984 novel by
Walter Tempest cruises character is
wildly inconsistent here when we first
see him he's this eccentric show-off but
as the movie goes along he goes from a
very respectful reserved character to
whiny to angry and back to eccentric
again and it doesn't happen in a way
that suggests a narc this results in
uneven performance know something I'm a
fucking animal
I have to mention that Paul Newman won
an Oscar for his portrayal of Fast Eddie
it's interesting because it was 25 years
since he first played this character in
the early 60s he was great here and it
makes me want to go back and check out
the original film
have you seen The Hustler let me know
what you think about it in the comments
below as for Cruz I think if this was
just a couple years later he could have
really hung with Newman in the color of
money but the way it turned out just
sort of left the young star as an
afterthought number two Lestat delay in
court in interview with the vampire The
Vampire Chronicles did some but they say
vampire ah-ah-ah-ah
he's supposed to be some kind of uh
Disney Prince or something I'm a vampire
Halloween's over me
that now I feel stupid based on the Anne
Rice novel a vampire named Lewis tells
his history to an enthusiastic
biographer his tale starts after the
death of his family when he's confronted
by a vampire named Lestat and is
convinced to join him as a creature of
the night the depressed Lewis and
fun-loving Lestat butt heads on almost
everything and the relationship is made
even more complicated when the stop lets
a young girl named Claudia join their
family this movie is very sexual I know
that vampires have almost always had
that characteristic about them but this
movie is drenched in weird dull
sexuality like everything they do is
over sexualized how are we going
[Music]
no it just that's all I have left to
learn I can do that Cruz trying to be
scary doesn't work out too great
his character motivations are very
muddled and he's not intimidating enough
to be threatening why should I know
these things do you know him noise it's
driving me mad that noise we've been in
the country for weeks nothing but that
noise there are two scary parts with him
in it he dances with a body dead of the
plague which is at the least
pretty darn ghoulish but there's a part
in this movie where he turns back up
after a short absence and that whole
scene is definitely unsettling the sad
became something like himself Claudia
it's been a very very naughty girl
that's about it though maybe Tom Cruise
just isn't scary have you ever felt this
I take that back and the number one
worst Tom Cruise performance is Jack in
legend
Tom Cruise in legend darkness is looking
to cast an eternal light onto the world
by killing the last unicorn princess
Lilly is also soon captured by the demon
now forest boy Jack and his magical
friends must do everything they can to
stop darkness and save the world
directed by Ridley Scott legend is an
interesting movie I actually enjoyed a
good portion of it the makeup and
effects work in this movie are amazing
so before we get into Cruz's performance
I want to talk about what I like in this
movie number one devil Tim Curry dude he
looks amazing
I love it he's fantastic in this that
voice is perfect and the costume and
makeup on darkness is phenomenal
also Meg buckle bones the swamp witch
was legitimately one of the best effects
I've ever seen and made me audibly say
wow the work that went into making that
character more than paid off can't say
enough good things about that scene you
simply don't see effects work like that
nowadays it's really refreshing to not
see a CG cartoon there by the way love
Frankie Muniz is Gump there's something
about this movie that's very attractive
it's got some heart and a good idea for
a story unfortunately it just doesn't
know how to put it together very well
it's a shame because this could have
been a very significant fantasy film
instead of just a great spectacle I saw
the director's cut so let me know in the
comments what the difference is from the
theatrical version are in which you like
better now on to Cruz's performance
everything in this movie is very
whimsical I mean there's glitter
everywhere Cruz is always full of wonder
and Quincy seriously most of his scenes
contain him crouching and staring with a
blank expression how about a little
facial movement there Tom I know he's
supposed to be this fanciful character
but it's just too awkward and he's also
not interesting enough to keep your
attention when all these incredible
environments are around him these roles
are pretty irrelevant in the long run
Tom Cruise at 54 is still one of the
biggest action stars in the world before
I sign off today I'd like to once again
implore you to please help out cancer
survivor and one of my friends Barry
Piotrowski he beat Hodgkin's lymphoma a
few years ago and was wrongfully
abandoned by his insurance company left
to pay all his
medical bills by himself Barry is also a
professional wrestler and I made a
documentary about him a few years ago
you can help him by buying this shirt
the link is in the description below
along with the trailer for the
documentary he's one of my closest
friends and did not deserve what
happened to him please help him out if
you can and you'll get a pretty cool
shirt you won't regret it
I want to hear what you guys think what
is your least favorite Tom Cruise movie
and/or performance who do you want me to
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let me know if you haven't already
make sure to go back and check out my
top 5 best Tom Cruise performances
follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and come back next
week when we change things up a bit on a
brand new top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you